رصدت الجزيره عشرات سفن شحن وناقلات عالقه
في المياه الاقليميه الجيبوتيه بعدما
تقطعت بها السبل نظرا لعدم قدرتها على
المرور عبر مضيق باب المندب بسبب الوضع
المتوتر في البحر الاحمر وقال مصدر ملاحي
للجزيره ان السفن العالقه قد تضطر الى
تعديل مسارها والالتفاف الى راس الرجاء
الصالح اذا استمرت الهجمات في هذه المنطقه
واشار المصدر الى ان القوات البحريه
المشتركه طلبت من السفن الابتعاد خلال هذه
الفتره عن باب المندب وتوقعت ان تستمر
فتره التهديد للسفن والناقلات لعده
ايام نرصد هذا الوضع لهذه السفن العالقه
في جيبوتي مع مراسلنا من ميناء جيبوتي حسن
رزاق مشاهداتك اولا حسن والارقام المتوفره
عن عدد هذه السفن وجهاتها وايضا
جنسياتها
فعلا المعطيات المتوفره حتى هذه اللحظه
انه بسبب استمرار الاشتباكات المسلحه بين
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا من جهه وجماعه
الحوثي من جهه اصبحت هذه المنطقه بؤره
نزاع مسلح وبالتالي هناك تخوف من كثير من
السفن من العبور في المرحله الحاليه من
مضيق ماب المندب كما تشاهدون خلفي تظهر
بعض السفن التي تقطعت بها السبل طبعا هي
تتواجد حاليا في المياه الاقليميه الجب
وتريد ان تتجه شمالا نحو مضيق باب المندب
ومنه الى قناه السويس لكن هي ما زالت
رابضه بسبب تحذيرات من القوه المشتركه
والتي اشارت والتي طلبت ايضا من كثير من
السفن عدم العبور في هذه الفتره من مضيق
باب الندب سما مع التهديدات من جماعه
الحوثي بالرد والانتقام من ال الضربات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه وبالتالي اصبحت هذه
المنطقه
بؤره نزاع مسلح تخشى الكثير من السفون حتى
وان لم كن تتجه الى اسرائيل تخشى من قذائف
الطائشه او يتم استهدافها بالخطا وبالتالي
هي ت تفضل البقاء ريثما تهدى الاوضاع لكن
بعض السفن مع طول انتظار هذه الفتره قد
ت تقرر التفاف من خلال راس الرجاء الصالح
للوصول الى وجهته لا سيما ان حتى هذه
اللحظه ليس ما هو معروف الفتره التي قد
تمكث هنا قد تزيد اكثر من اسبوع او
اسبوعين وبالتالي تفضل الاستفاد من هذا
الوقت لكن على اي حال كان هذا متوقعا بسبب
توتر هذه المنطقه واستمرار التوتر سيما من
من حيث الفعل الامريكي والبريطاني ورد
الفعل المتوقع من جماعه الحوثي اكثر السفن
اثرت الانتظار على هذه المناطق وهي
القريبه من مابل المد في المياه الاقليميه
الجيبوتيه حتى يتضح او حتى تستطيع ان تحصل
على مرور امني من القوه الامنيه المشتركه
التي حذرتهم من عدم العبور في هذه المرحله
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا حسن رزاق من ميناء
جيبوتي